hi Kelly thank you for including me in
your good neighbor campaign my name is
Nick Heath and I'm from London England
and I recently gained a bit a global
notoriety after my hashtag live
commentary videos went a little bit
viral Nellore just over the helican
logistics chokolate in hot pursuit well
these guys are really going for it
flower after flower I'm a play-by-play
announcer I think you would call it over
there a good old sports commentator we'd
say here in England and as the sporting
occasion is started disappearing from
the calendar when I was looking like
having no work to do so I decided I'd go
out around my local neighbourhood and
apply my commentary to some basic
everyday things there's been some lovely
footwork and there it is again from
Manila that's excellent the spaniel now
out in front and that's confused the
hell out of it I'm thrilled to say that
people have found them entertaining
we're gonna get a second nap it's just
beginning to build up so no she breaks
it off just as quickly quick Whittle
after that one I should think whether
they're key workers or people finding
this whole time pretty anxious I've had
hundreds if not thousands of messages
from people saying that I've given them
a much-needed belly laugh you join me
live in a popular high street discount
clothing store this chap hoping to get a
personal best in the find a fashion
bargain steeplechase it's a real
humbling gift to give and listen for
those of you watching let's keep this
going join the campaign so that we can
be hashtag good neighbors together
does he like it Oh oh it's got a
whacking great big logo in the middle of
it will he make do will he decide to go
with it yes it looks like he will he
will he will and regret it later
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going